well before I get to a clip here from
MSNBC of democratic representative
Maxwell Frost talking about a proposal a
bill actually he's introduced to create
an office of gun violence prevention
and uh great idea and all around we need
more action specifically by Republicans
for them to get on board with common
sense solutions to gun violence
decreasing the Carnage we experience in
America
before we get to that though we have
seen yet another devastating mass
shooting and this is what is being
responded to in the clip I'm about to
show you
um hear from the Lexington Herald Leader
a gunman opened fire in a downtown
Louisville Bank Monday morning killing
at least five people and hospitalizing
eight others the Louisville Metro Police
Department confirms few details have
emerged but by Monday afternoon about
the shooter or their victims but
emotional Governor uh Andy Bashar did
say one of the deceased as
oh my gosh as a very close friend during
a news conference while this is
Kentucky's first mass shooting of 2023
it's the 146 mass shooting in the U.S
just this year that's according to the
gun violence archive 146 mass shootings
just this year
in America
and as I said in the last segment on
today's show it is a multi-faceted
approach to decrease gun violence to
address this problem but you can't
ignore one of the primary components
which is the gun
that is how we are set
so far apart from other countries When
comparing developed countries their gun
violence the reality of guns in the
regulation and there's two ways that are
clear and present
and undeniable
um
two ways that we are very different from
other developed countries
the first is the amount and how
unregulated our guns are
and the second is how much gun balance
we have so you can connect the dots
there
and we don't have to be seeing this type
of
um
Devastation on such a regular basis here
is democratic representative Maxwell
Frost talking about his proposal for an
office of gun violence prevention we
need people who are forward-thinking
progressive candidates and thinking
about ways of how we're going to end gun
violence at every level of government I
actually just introduced my first bill
which creates a federal office of gun
violence prevention which will help do
just that work with Municipal Cities
state governments and Congress to
provide recommendations and give the
data that we need to solve this problem
holistically but what we will refuse is
politicians who go in front of cameras
and say oh it's going to happen anyway
there's nothing we can do if that is
what you if that's the energy you're
bringing to this problem you don't
belong in the seat of power you don't
belong in a place where you represent
the people because every death is a
policy failure
yeah
uh so while it would absolutely be
something I'd support to set up an
office of gun violence prevention it
also should be noted
while there is
absolutely complexity to how we go about
solving this in another way it's simple
in terms of what the next step has to be
and the only way reasonably
realistically we're going to address and
decrease gun violence in the United
States is for the Republican party to
change their stance on this that's just
the reality and so down the road there
are so many fascinating complex
conversations about how we go about
generally addressing crime and gun
violence mass shootings all that
but the next step has to be we Implement
Common Sense gun regulation and What's
blocking that the Republican party next
moment from this interview
I think we're going to continue to see
that this youth litter turnout will
continue to rise we've seen the past
three Cycles have had wildly amazing
youth Hood turnout numbers and we're not
done yet you know in 2020 we had the
highest youth litter turnout in the
history of our country and half of gen Z
can't even vote yet meanwhile the
Republican party is focused on changing
the voters and you know there's
something wrong with your policy party
when your path to Victory is changing
the voters and gerrymandering our maps
to hell and that's what's going on right
now it's anti-democratic it's not
democracy and it's not the freedom and
liberty that the party tends to hold up
the Republican Party holds up as their
Banner true patriotism is loving the
people in the country it's not just
about the flag it's about the people in
the country and it's something that this
generation gen Z and young folks
understand and that's why we're going to
continue to fight we will vote but we
also will hit the streets and we also
will take care of one another and I I
think that holistic interpretation of
what a movement is is part of the reason
why in Young Folks are going to really
build political power quickly in this
country it's using every single tool in
our toolbox
so uh I really do like that line of true
patriotism is loving the people in the
country it's not just about the flag
it's about the people in the country and
I think that highlights
what we'll see
um from
many within the Republican Party
this
uh
this insistence on focusing on things
that are much more symbolic than they
are
actually impacting people in their
day-to-day life and that is why in large
part they distract with a lot of these
what are referred to as culture War
issues things that are uh vague enough
abstract enough and symbolic enough
where you can get people riled up about
it but not actually be held to any
standard it's not a tangible promise
that you can be held to and his example
of
patriotism being about the people and
not about the flag it's great to
have the flag as a representation of our
country and all that but when patriotism
to you is just symbolic it's just
wearing the flag it's just
um
whatever it might be your
the way you go about uh saying the
Pledge of Allegiance and the hand over
heart and all that and all of it can be
great and wonderful
but let that let's make sure that's not
a replacement for what his actual
patriotism
which is
fighting for the Improvement of the
lives of people within the country and
David has recently talked about someone
I think wrote Into the show or called on
the show
um and talked about how Republicans are
able to kind of co-opt these terms these
positive terms patriotism and it is
theirs or even the flag an American flag
being a republican thing often which is
strange
um it's all of our flag but
it it definitely happens The Branding
the messaging within the Republican
Party often is more effective if even if
dishonest
um and I think
those on the left need to work harder to
make sure we don't just allow the
conversations to always be on their Turf
because no I don't think it's patriotic
to spend all your time focusing on your
obsession with
you know your guns and and flag shirt
instead of focusing on protecting
children in schools based on common
sense Solutions
um and I don't think it's patriotic to
allow
so many people to be in poverty in this
country and
um not getting enough in the proper food
and we could list off the racial
inequality that we have the
um rolling back of rights for women that
we're seeing and on and on it goes
that's not patriotic to me if you really
loved your country
you would love the people in it and if
you really loved your country and the
people in it then you would want to
solve problems facing those people
seems pretty clear to me but obviously a
lot of people don't buy into that and
it's all about the songs and the flags
instead of
the people much more after this